hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played yesterday in
round five of the saint louis rapid
event it is already furious versus
fabiano caruana and alireza had a great
first day he won two games got one draw
and he went as a leader uh to start day
two he then got a drug in jeffree chung
and now uh here he is in round five has
the white pieces against fabiano caruana
whereas fabi had a pretty bad um well uh
first day uh well uh
to his standards maybe not to everyone's
standards but he was without a win on
the first day and he's yet to score a
win on the second day and this is
already game five so this is a really
wild one fabi goes for the berlin
defense and alireza just really tries to
go uh a head first through the berlin
wall uh and let's see what happens when
you try that against a player like fabi
so alireza has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 we have pawn to e5 we
already announced that the berlin
defense knight f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 the royal lopez is on the
board knight to f6 the berlin defense
and now d3 uh we have bishop to c5 uh
pawn to c3 and the ball players castle
so castles castles and now d6 and bishop
to g5 so this is all very standard stuff
nothing new here h6 chasing the bishop
away bishop h4 g5 bishop to g3 and now
knight h5 putting pressure on the bishop
here knight beat to d2 and now queen to
f6 and the position is a known one and
uh what's uh even more interesting is
that um
even though fab is playing this with the
black pieces uh he scored a great
victory against david howell in the uh
2021 feeder grand swiss with the white
pieces from this position in that the
game uh favi started with bishop
captures on c6 but here alireza uh does
not play bishop captures on c6 and
instead he plays pawn to d4 and
interestingly pawn to d4 is a new move
so already as of movie 11 we have a
completely new game now it's uh uh it's
a question whether alireza mixed up
lines or he really uh
gave fabi this tiny bit of an edge in
order to try and uh create some sort of
uh
madness on the board but the the
positions that arise now are are simply
spectacular and uh
uh obviously yeah if you don't know how
to counter this um uh precisely you will
have to calculate here and fabi does not
go uh for the seemingly uh
first rep
refutation uh i will show it to you
because it's a lot of fun it's just a
one big capture fest in the center so
best for black would be to play e
characters on d4 now bishop captures in
c6 knight captures on g3 h captures d
captures on c3 now and now b captures in
c3 you could also try e5 but it doesn't
work unfortunately b captures in c3 b
captures on c6 and now pawn to e5 uh
messing up black spawn structure also
freeing up d for square for the knight
it will attack the queen and the bishop
here so the captures 94 attacks queen
and the bishop and once the queen moves
you have to keep an eye on the bishop
now you play queen a4 or something maybe
that alireza had in mind as he had this
prepared and you would have this
position where white has a very very
active game but black is up two pawns
and black does have the bishop fair
so it's a real really dynamic position
uh who's to say what would happen if
this occurred on the board but a similar
position did occur after d4 uh first
fabi went for knight captures on g3 h
captures and now he just plays e
captures on d4 bishop captures on c6 d
captures on c3 now uh and now uh he
throws in a nice bishop captures on b7
so not b captures um on c3 like we
discussed here all it is that goes to
bishop captures and b7 so he grabs one
more pawn but he also develops fabi's
light square bishop by doing so so
bishop captures b characters in c3 queen
captures on c3 and not just rogue b1
putting pressure on that bishop and b7
and here fabi plays bishop to b6 now the
bishop is no longer hanging on b7 and if
you look at the position now fabi six
points all there is a five pawns and
who's to say what is happening here one
thing that i'm sure even if fabi doesn't
know uh this position by heart is that
if it was possible to play like this he
would or rather he should know it and
even if he doesn't he knows that he
should not have any problems here but if
you look at this bishop pair that is one
nice bishop pair unless it's losing by
force by some uh you know rogue b5 rook
captures a knight captures and g5 queen
to h5 ideas like i mean it does look
like there might be something there but
if it's possible to defend fabi should
be able to calculate it so here we have
pawn to a4
but just rook a to b8 you don't really
have to worry about a5 or anything um
the bishop and queen cover that so rook
the b5 uh now preparing to shift the
rook over to f5 but also allowing fabi
bishop to a6 and this will win material
by force now the question is only
whether fabi will go for this or not he
has to calculate precisely he does go
for it bishop to a6 and now
rook to a rook to f5 and now can fabi
capture the rook on f1 if he can uh then
alireza obviously is is bluffing too
hard but if he can't he might get
checkmated at some knight captures on g5
queen h5 action and all of a sudden uh
you're lost so here fabi accepts the
challenge he plays bishop captures on f1
and now uh alireza has to uh take a
moment to capture the bishop back with
knight captures on f1 the problem with
knight captures and g5 even though it
looks very good for example if captures
then rook captures with check followed
by queen h5 uh black doesn't really have
to capture the knight black and just
play bishop somewhere and that's it if
you play queen to h5 just queen to g7
and everything is defended this is
defended this is defended uh there's no
good continuation here for alireza so
knight captures on f1 instead and now
rook f the e8 and here uh the rook is no
longer defending the f7 pawn and this
gives alireza the idea that if he
doesn't take the pawn on g5 now he never
will and he's just gonna be down
material for the rest of the game and he
does go for it knight captures on g5
fabi grabs it h character assign g5 and
queen to h5 vale it is up now with the
thread of queen captures on g5 but also
with the thread of queen captures on f7
so how can fabi defend this well here
fabi plays just a spectacular move and
that is bishop captures on f2 look at
this spectacular move
uh it seems that all it is i can capture
the bishop with the rook and with the
king
but it only seems that way the problem
with king captures is that now queen d4
check and we have a king hunt here king
of three queen captures with king f2
rook to b2 with check and that's it king
g1 queen captures on g1 with checkmate
and if you don't if you play uh rook
captures an f2 then you no longer have a
rook here to attack the g5 pawn just
going back to g7 and you enjoyed the
material advantage of course if the rule
goes back rook f5 you can play some like
rookie 5 and the g5 pawn is nicely
defended so instead after bishop
captures an f2 already says all right
you you definitely have something there
i'ma just move my king here king h2 and
now fabi goes back queen to g7 and what
is this now now fabi's inviting
rook captures on g5 and this way alireza
can win the queen on g7 uh the problem
is if valerisa goes for this uh fabi
just plays rook to e6 and this is the
only winning move so uh fabi had to
really find it this one rook to e6 now
the point is if rook captures on g7 and
king captures you have uh there there's
no defense against the rook to h6 or
rook to h8 uh the bishop covers g3 and
g1 uh the king will have no square so
basically you will checkmate the white
king you have one check a queen uh or
rather queen to g for check but doesn't
really matter rook g6 now there are no
more useful checks in the next move or
rook h6 and it's game over there there's
no defending this position so after
queen to g7 alireza has to again waste
the move to capture material rook
captures on f2 and now fabi just plays
rook captures on e4 all it is that
repeats rook to f5 but now just rook to
e5 and there really isn't a way for
alvarez to continue playing this he
played knight to e3 but not just queen
to h8 fabi forces a queen trade and he
was in this position on move 26 that
alireza firucha resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh point is uh the queens now get traded
off it doesn't matter if you capture or
fabby captures for example captures
captures and now how do you defend uh
you of course don't want to trade
because you're down material also your
knight is hanging and if you play rook
f3 just rook b3 there's no stopping the
trade you're gonna have to move the
knight just captures captures now it's a
clean rook against the knight also
fabi's up two pawns this is an easily
winning position for him
so uh it's hard to say if alireza uh
missed the bishop characters uh captures
and then d4 or rsd for some sort of a
cool new way of trying to
provoke the the the berlin players into
weakening their positions a little bit
uh but if anything i'm pretty sure that
fabi is the last person you want to try
something like this against as he the
man defends like a machine and here uh
he just did exactly that
uh so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed this really a wild one we also
have um
i can even show it to you it's a nice
photo of them having a nice handshake
after the game so i know how much you
guys enjoyed that i'm pretty sure i had
it somewhere let me just check uh yeah
there it is uh oh let me just make this
a little bit smaller uh a very nice
photo by leonard otis uh so do check it
out and uh the the rest of his work uh
there you have it uh alireza finishing
the game with 15 seconds on the clock
fabi having uh way way too much time on
the clock and alireza was forced to
resign here
uh so yeah very very nicely done uh but
even uh after losing this game already
defeated dominguez in the final round or
rather in game uh in round six uh and uh
he is now again the leader after uh the
the first day so alireza in seoul first
followed by iannipomnishi maxim bashir
lagrav and jeffrey shiong in in shared
second place we'll see what happens
after day three and then we are going to
check out the
exact standings as i know you guys enjoy
that as well uh so yeah once again i
hope you enjoyed it uh you know it's uh
always try to push for more but uh
always also be careful that your
opponent is not fabiano carwana uh so i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to lenny yeah and i would like to thank
gregory obama conor kelly john merlino
and the daemon targaryen for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day